when you uh put the night vision on and
you look at the stars and you look out
there in in the vast Cosmos only a small
fraction of which we can see
um how many intelligent alien
civilizations do you think are out there
do you think about this kind of stuff I
do
you know I'm of the theory that we are
not the only people out there I think
it's it's it would be a statistically
silly comment to assume we are although
I get that we are the only data point
that we currently have although I'm
willing to jump over that fence and say
that yes there most likely is
intelligent life elsewhere uh although
I'll concede that it is a possibility we
are early or it could be limited or it
could be in a manner that we don't
recognize or can really understand I I
spend so much time thinking about how we
anthropomorphize things on this UFO
topic and we've done it to ourselves
with media in a sense right we've
trained ourselves what to think about
what we think is true or what this would
be like and by doing so I think we're
closing ourselves off to a lot of what
the possibilities could be and the
things that we could miss